mary lou macdonald thanks for thanks for
talking to me and being on the show this
week lots going on and lots to talk
about now you told me this week that the
notion that the uk government would seek
to rewrite
part of the post-brexit trade deal was
to quote you shocking and outrageous
but the foreign secretary liz trust has
announced that the uk intends to do this
in the coming weeks and while you may
not like it
do you accept that it's a necessary step
now to get storment up and running again
no i i don't i i think the decision by
the british government to
step outside of international law in
fact worse than that
to legislate to break the law
is an extremely dangerous place to go i
think it demonstrates really bad faith
in fact i think it amplifies the kind of
bad faith that we've seen from the boris
johnson's government since brexit and it
certainly does nothing let me repeat
does nothing to assist in the very
necessary goal of urgently and
immediately establishing an executive
and government in the north of ireland
this is a mixture of
gamesmanship within the tory party i
think
between different political factions
perhaps some with with leadership
aspirations it is certainly a game of
chicken with the european commission
with the european institutions
and the north of ireland finds itself
caught
in this cross right bearing in mind that
the north of ireland did not vote to
brexit in fact people in the north again
what the government would say is that
they are is it they're not breaking
international law by changing elements
rather than
scrapping the deals you see the the
difficulty is that they are so they're
sorry so no sorry there isn't a gray
area on this you can't kind of be
compliant or not okay the the government
the british government is well aware
there is an established channel
a
a committee where issues around
implementation where those areas that
need to be smoothed out and let me say
and i said this to boris johnson at our
meeting yes there are areas that need to
be smoothed out there is a meeting of
minds on that that's not in dispute
there is also a mechanism through which
that can happen but nowhere is there
provision for any party to the agreement
to unilaterally tear even part of the
agreement you do accept at least that
the uk government does have a right to
unilaterally act to safeguard peace and
stability in northern ireland that's
written into the agreement isn't it
that's that's not what they're doing and
you do not secure stability
peace or any level of certainty in
ireland by acting in a unilateral
fashion and it has to be said and i put
this to the to the to the british prime
minister at our meeting
and last october unionism walked away
the dup walked away from the north south
arrangements that's part of the good
friday agreement there wasn't one word
out of boris johnson he made no
statement he gave no reaction
i'm skeptical
as to the bona fides of this government
and their so-called commitment to
protecting the peace arrangements the
evidence system
in
the protocol says if the application of
the protocol leads to serious economic
societal environmental difficulties you
know this that a libel uh to persist or
diversion of trade the eu or the uk may
unilaterally take appropriate safeguard
measures
so from the government's perspective the
uk government's perspective they're
worried about what they see as grave and
serious problems
about peace and stability in northern
ireland so they feel that they have a
right to act unilaterally you do
acknowledge that though so they might
not agree with it but you do acknowledge
that they do have that so the the
article 16 provision is essentially
a review provision which can be
unilaterally triggered but needs to be
signaled to the other party of course
i'm more than familiar with that what
article 16 is not is a permission for
any party to the agreement to
unilaterally step outside and do their
own thing and let me say this there's a
lot of talk about the protocol and it's
not working there are areas paper
barriers that need to be sorted out by
the way they're a consequence of brexit
but let me tell you this uh the notion
that there is some kind of economic
catastrophe in the north of ireland is
simply not true in fact if you examine
the evidence
of how the north of ireland is faring
you will see that they uniquely have
access to the british market but they
also have access to the european market
unencumbered unhindered and
a market of 500 million people and let
me also tell you without the protocol
and the provisions in it agriculture and
agribusiness in the north which is a
considerable part of the economy finds
itself in very big but mcdonald's
it's not working for everyone i i met
with a businessman yesterday he owns a
small uh shot he owns a great deli
actually and he is struggling with
import costs and paperwork and the
prices are going up
and there are winners and losers in all
of this
but isn't the point
that all unionists not just the dup
are opposed to the protocol
and do you acknowledge that and
understand why they feel aggrieved and
acknowledge that that is a problem
whether you agree with it or not it's a
massive problem let me let me deal with
each of those uh issues in turn the the
delhi owner
the paperwork the fact that that that
brexit has thrown up this
this blizzard of paper in some instances
is problematic i i acknowledge that as
was the issue for example around
medicines and any question mark over
people's ability to access the medicines
that were that were required the
medicines issue got sorted out before
christmas on the issue of the paper
burden there is a proposal from the
european commission on the table that's
what needs to be examined that proposal
suggests that you could see a reduction
of 80 or 85 percent of that
administrative burden that is the
constructive grown-up responsible way to
deal with this issue the unionist
position
as regards the protocol is kind of
ironic in one way because
the very people who argued for the
hardest possible brexit are the people
who now lament the consequences of a
very hard brexit which let me finish
which is which is the which is the
protocol and
they have a view that they don't wish to
see checks or as they put a border in in
the irish sea but they also argued for
brexit and they were told consistently
that this would cause a problem and it
has and it now turns out that the
problem is there is but it has and it
needs resolving
and
if all unionists are opposed to the
protocol you know regardless of what
they thought when they were agreeing to
which deal or what deal
that in that context
it can't be unchanged
if you're serious about a partnership
installment whatever the rights and
wrongs of the past it has to change for
the assembly to get up and running again
if all unionists are opposed to it you
acknowledge that well well look there is
no there is no uh impediment towards the
the executive getting up and running
except that one party and it's very
important to say this not all unions are
saying we will not go into the executive
in fact the ulster unionist party's
position is that they stand ready to
form an executive with the rest of us we
have one problem party in the dup they
refuse to countenance a new government
despite all of the pressures that people
in ireland and further afield are
experiencing
so yes there have been
there have been concerns raised about
the protocol i have outlined to you the
channels that exist to address those
matters but it's also important to say
this
the dup does not have a veto on these
matters they have expressed their
reviews they have expressed their views
repeatedly their concerns have been
heard many of their concerns can be
addressed what cannot be facilitated
is either a veto by one party that says
to society until we get our way it's no
way that's not acceptable and what's
also not acceptable is the british
government boris johnson or liz truss or
anybody else deciding that they can act
unilaterally act in such bad faith i
mean that is so debilitating to the kind
of good relationships that we need
you've been condemning the dup for not
entering government but they've done
simply what shin fein have done in the
past too i mean you've been in a
position
where champaign have frustrated storm
being up and running as well i mean well
the distinction
i could say is this
the last time that the last time well
let me let me outline for for your
viewers the nature of the grievance at
the time was a financial scandal the
likes of which would have taken down any
government in any jurisdiction anywhere
in the world let me also say this beyond
that scandal there was an investigation
an inquiry and so on there was an
election and within a year we had a deal
actually agreed with the dup and they
walked away from that deal repeatedly
actually behavior that is now repeated
in this scenario we are now here we are
at this point in time we are living
through war in europe who would have
thought we would see such a calamity a
cost of living crisis the people haven't
seen for 20 or 30 years
we cannot have a situation where society
is held to ransom because the dup won't
listen to the democratic voice of the
people and they are aided and abetted in
that regard by boris johnson that is a
disgraceful shameful system more
questions i know and run out of time but
if the uk government initiates
unilateral actions on the protocol do
you think there will be a trade war do
you fear a trade war
well i i fear in the first instance that
we are we are left in a state of limbo
in the north of ireland the peace
process has taken considerable
investment by everybody concerned and i
don't think it should be thrown away
disrupted or damaged in such a
high-handed cavalier fashion there would
i i believe be a response from the from
europe if it is a thing that the british
government insists and moves ahead and
moves unilaterally
what that might be i'm not going to i'm
not going to speculate you know what it
might be you must have had conversations
well i'm not going to speculate i'm not
going to add um flames to what's already
a very difficult situation but i think
boris johnson and his government are are
fully aware that in circumstances
where a government steps outside
international law acts in bad faith of
course there will be a response to that
i would urge and i would appeal even at
this stage
for good sense for common sense for
responsible politics to prevail
competent politics as well
where a government that has an issue
that wishes to see a number of issues
addressed has the competence and the
good faith to actually employ the
channels that are available and then let
us in ireland let people in the north of
ireland get on with it have government
and make the progress that we are
entitled to anticipate in our society
i've said all along
we can't be the collateral damage for
britain's brexit let me put it another
way then you
you it seems to me that what you're
saying is that you do fear a trade war
would you advocate the eu to take
retaliatory trade measures well well i
haven't said that and don't put words in
my mouth what i have said what i have
said
is i think any grown-up person would
realize that in circumstances where one
party to an agreement acts in absolute
bad faith consistently and insists on
legislating unilaterally to breach
international law of course you can
anticipate that there will be a response
to that how could there not be you see
the nature of these things is that you
decide to work in partnership you act in
good faith when you sign agreements you
honor them and you certainly stay within
the parameters of the law i don't think
there is anything exceptional in me
making these points and i would have
thought
in the mother of all parliaments as
westminster claims that mantle that it
would be unconscionable
unconscionable for any right-minded tory
labour party member from any political
stripe that you would legislate to break
the law that has an implication for
britain
uh way beyond this particular scenario
and and causes us a huge problem here in
ireland so i'm appealing for good sense
good politics and good faith to prevail
one final question i know i'm out of
time but it was a historic election in
which shin fame is now the party with
the first minute minister elect border
pole in northern ireland can only be
called by the british secretary of state
that's positioned the good friday
agreement when had she when should he or
she do that now when more than 50 of the
population vote for nationalist parties
can you give us a clue of how that might
unfold well actually it
i have put that question so many times
to the secretary of state and indeed to
the prime minister and to theresa may
when she was prime minister in her time
i think it's actually very important
that we set out the parameters of that
we need an indication from the british
government as to how they might measure
when they would regard us uh to be
appropriate or the time for a border
pole to happen but for me more urgently
what needs to happen now is we need to
begin that preparation for
constitutional change that is orderly
that is democratic and that is peaceful
ireland has changed ireland is changing
and this is a moment of huge opportunity
for this island
it will be challenging for sure but but
what i know is that we can achieve
orderly constitutional change but we
will have to plan for it so there's a
huge obligation on the government in
dublin but also a real requirement now
for that kind of rigorous impartiality
that the good friday agreement uh
envisages the good faith that's
necessary from the government in london
of any stripe to actually act in good
faith and to demonstrate goodwill to
ireland as we emerge from a history of
colonialism and conflict and and all of
that but into a future that can be
incredibly right for us so at that will
be a united ireland and it will happen
in our time it is change is imminent so
we need to prepare now you and i are
about the same age i think so you think
it will happen in our life oh absolutely
without a shadow of a doubt i believe
that we will we will see constitutional
change in the course probably of the
next decade of of that there is no doubt
and we need to prepare for that and the
appetite for change across ireland is
you know would would really lift your
heart but the the opportunity that
exists for our country and we need to
bring our unionist brothers and sisters
along that road with us and i believe
it's the job of both governments dublin
and london to act scrupulously in good
faith to allow the irish people to form
and decide that future together
peacefully
democratically and in an orderly fashion
a border pole within the next decade
oh yes for sure border poles there will
have to be two
north and south that's with some visage
next year the good friday agreement will
be 25 years old a quarter of a century
of achievement so the question naturally
arises what next michelle o'neill will
be the first nationalist the first
republican first minister in the north
of ireland estate that was particularly
constructed and engineered to prevent a
michelle o'neill ever becoming first
minister but that's the level of change
that's happened in ireland um and i
think that is a source of
uh great optimism and hope and challenge
for all of us but uh we will we will get
there
mary lou macdonald thank you so much my
pleasure thank you